he's becoming a person he's got such a
personality and opinions and he's
talking now so it's just such a fun
phase
yes two and a half-year-old hayes is
along for the ride with his mama during
her epic tour everyone kind of warns you
about toddler years but honestly
well i mean like he's got he's they
can't regulate their emotions so i've
been there but honestly it's really fun
i feel like this is when they really
come alive and so this has been one of
my i always say each phase is my
favorite this one has been the most fun
oh it gets better and better yeah it
really does
and the song hummingbird you know you
have him saying mama in it
mama
[Music]
now that you sing the song or you hear
the song does it feel different totally
i wrote hummingbird the day i found out
i was pregnant and now he's two and he's
on the road with me and every time i
sing that song on stage on this tour
it's like he's on the bus sleeping it's
just amazing to kind of have that full
circle moment of creating that song
while he was being created
and marin's also creating some fun for
her crew
[Applause]
i started playing tennis during the
pandemic and everyone was telling me
that pickleball is really fun if you
like tennis as a tour activity it's been
a great bonding experience because
sometimes on tours like i've had my band
forever but you have like new crew
people out and i feel like this has been
a really fun way for me to get to know
some of the new crew members it's like a
good team building experience you're
really having a lot of fun aren't you
i am
[Applause]
[Music]